le cdas 9 7 4 tv et le département d
vous présente le 12e concours de calcul
rapide
alors on commence le deuxième concours
de calcul rapide de 2015 à mes côtés
mathieu lambert professeur de
mathématiques et les deux mondes du jury
en face de moi mais c'est l'inspecteur
de saint-pierre monsieur geslin et
monsieur jean-claude fénélon directeur
d'école à cet ambre et on va commencer
d'abord par le niveau mais c'est u2 on
appelle les deux premiers candidats
lanoux et blanche
te présenter bonjour je m'appelle amour
j'ai mon nom et chen yunlin
je viens de son mari je suis en ce2 à
l'école de passants bonjour je m'appelle
blanche va c'est le tiennent cois je
suis en co2 et je suis à l'école léon
dierx descendez vous alors vous vous
expliquer comment ça va se dérouler donc
chaque manche peut être composé de six
questions
les trois premières questions sont des
questions de calcul rapide
vous aurez à chaque fois le chat calcul
sera lui deux fois mais vous aurez 10
secondes de réflexion
ensuite viendront les trois problème
donc pour chaque problème vous aurez
pareil de lecture et 20 secondes de
réflexion dépendant le problème vous
pourrez si vous le souhaitez prendre des
notes sur la feuille sur la feuille de
papier qui est placé devant vous de la
dca chaque nation et lui vous pouvez à
tout moment
donc même y compris dès la première
lecture vous pouvez ici basé sur la
tablette qui est présente devant vous et
donc il est bien entendu le premier qui
baisent pourra donner donner la réponse
si le premier qui baise de nouvelles
réponses dans ces cas là le deuxième
réponse je vous conseille de prendre son
temps dans le temps réglementaire donné
sa réponse
est ce que c'est bien compris oui eh
bien on va commencer
attention premiers calculs 824 +49 824
+49 873 c'est une bonne réponse
deuxième calcul 160 x 560 x 5 800 c'est
une belle réponse tu marques un poids
calcul est le temps de 440 est le camp
de 440 110 c'est une bonne réponse tu
marques à l'ordre à coup on fait un
petit petit aperçu la baie de la
première phase alors on va s'entraîner à
phrase blanche à deux points nous
continuons avec la deuxième partie
calcul réfléchit alors là vous pouvez
prendre aussi l'eau et par des notes si
vous voulez les problèmes
les havrais à son cours de danse il
commence à 9h30 et duire une oeuvre des
cornes à quelle heure c'était à linz en
cours
10h45 c'est une bonne réponse ça tu m'as
qu'un point
deuxième pilote non rouleaux de moquette
d'une longue de 100 m as et la coupe
plaisir ont respectivement 25 mètres 14
m et 39 m quelle longueur reste-t-il sur
le boulot dodo cas d'une longueur de 100
m on a fait trois coupes mais je
remplace captivant 25 mètres 14 m et 39
m quelle longueur reste-t-il sur le
rouleau
70 22 m c'est une bonne réponse
tu as toujours pas troisième problème
le médecin prescrit à stéphanie quatre
boîtes de fortifiants contenant chacune
12 en couleurs elle doit prendre quatre
ans coule par jour quelle est la durée
du traitement
trois jours c'est une mauvaise réponse
le médecin prescrit à stéphanie quatre
boîtes de fortifiants contenant chacune
deux ampoules
elle doit prendre 4 1 puis un jour
quelle est la durée du traitement
toujours c'est une bonne réponse tu m'as
bien qu'à ce stade il n'est plus ce que
c'était miné alors à ce stade à mieux à
4 points et blanches deux points donc
c'est à nous qui gagne à notre mais tu
es qualifié pour la finale tout à
l'heure ben vous pouvez gagner vos
places pour appeler les deux candidats
suivants on sait maintenant il va faire
le cm1 mobile et à fès
allez marion coup tu vas tu présenter
bonjour je m'appelle marie joséphine je
suis sincèrement le col de bast à sainte
marie bonjour je m'appelle à face à lyon
deux hommes se lient et jeux à l'école
jacques prévert de ça il qu'ils
ressentent
on va commencer toujours pas le premier
calcul du sang 50,75 - 81,25 de 130 500
30,50 alors ce n'est pas une bonne
réponse très 250,6 75 - 81,25 170 à 200
170 bienvenue 50
alors c'est une bonne réponse à votre
deuxième calcul est la moitié de 129
soit 164,5 la réponse est exacte
tu m'as compas troisième calcul entre
parenthèses 530 - 18 x entre parenthèses
31 - 21 entre parenthèses 530 - 18 x
entre parenthèses 31 - mater 5000 s'en
va c'est une bonne réponse tu marques
voilà donc un petit point alors à fès à
ce stade du jeu à deux pointes et marion
un point rien n'est perdu
donc on passe à la deuxième partie
calcul réfléchi premier problème pour
mesurer la longue d'une étable mène à
reporter cinq fois son double décimètre
et a encore mesuré 13,2 cm qu'elle est
en cm la longueur de la table
pour mesurer la longueur d'une étable
ben reporté cinq fois son double
décimètre est encore mesurée 13,2 cm
qu'elle est en cm que la longueur de la
table
pour que le temps est écoulé apparemment
donc personne n'a trouvé la bonne
réponse
donc on passe ça va demander au jury
d'expliquer wii speak adio alors cinq
fois il est utilisé donc son double
décimètre 5 fois 20 ça fait sens et est
plus très centimes à 2,2 donc sans plus
13 et u 2 s'affaissant 13,2 cm à passau
deuxième problème illuminer une vitrine
un décorateur utilise 5 guirlandes de
sang en poule et trois guirlandes
blanche de 50 ans coule
combien dans poule vont illuminer la
vitrine 650 poule c'est une bonne
réponse tu m'as pas donc il nous reste
le dernier problème donc on fait un
petit point à ce stade on a une égalité
parfaite 2 à 2 donc ce troisième
problème qui va certainement ou de
partager valérie achète six places de
cinéma en tout elle paye 72 euros
combien coûte une place de cinéma
valérie achète six places de cinéma le
temps est écoulé pour toi reste du temps
valérie achète six places de cinéma en
tout elle paye 62 euros combien coûte
une place 12 euros
c'est une bonne réponse tu vas
comprendre à la donc le total vélo la
finale alors total trois points à 2 pour
bénéfice de marion donc marion est
qualifié pour la finale de ce m
alors donc on va appeler les deux autres
candidats de cm2 et antoine
alors donc au cm2 vous allez vous
présenter les deux candidats bonjour je
m'appelle romain confier de l'école
borie de saint vincent de la ville de
saint denis
bonjour je m'appelle antoine les chiens
je suis en cm2 de l'école à la lorraine
à la position alors on va commencer par
la première partie ils calculent
automatisé premiers calculs
2 / 112 00 32
c'est une bonne réponse deuxième calcul
ajoute 99 à 354 ajoute 99 à 307 en 453
c'est exact tu m'as troisième calcul
26,42 multiplié par cinq
26,40 2 x 500 32,1 c'est une bonne
réponse tu marques un poids
alors passez à la deuxième partie comme
qu'elle réfléchisse pour prendre des
notes
premier problème roméo en vacances à un
forfait téléphonique glauque et de une
quand il a déjà téléphoné pendant 80
minutes
combien de temps lui reste-t-il sur son
fond fait dix minutes c'est une bonne
réponse artumas qu'un corps deuxième
problème madame durand veut
confectionner 5 rideaux toit chaque
rideau elle a besoin de 4 m de voile qui
coûte 7,50 euros le m combien dépense
rappelle 50 euros c'est une mauvaise
réponse
madame durand veut confectionner 5
rideau que chaque rue de l a besoin de 4
m de voile qui coûte 7 euros 50 le m
combien dépense rappelle 150 euros c'est
une bonne réponse tu marques un point
donc on fait un petit point que je suis
là c'est le dernier problème
alors romain à ce stade du jeu donc mène
donc il a deux points et one 3 points
devant comparses troisième problème
peuvent entourer son prix rectangulaire
de 350 mètres de long et 68 mètres de
large avec une clôture
quel longue de clôture doit-il acheter
tu attends 18 m ce n'est pas une bonne
réponse
entouré son prix rectangulaire de 350
mètres de long et 68 mètres de large
avec une clôture
quel ongles à des clôtures du at il
acheté 836 m c'est une bonne réponse
alors le final alors c'est antoine qui
mène le bal avec quatre points à deux
bombes et donc en antoine est qualifié
pour la finale
alors on va passer maintenant
dans la deuxième manche de ce2 on
appelle et quand vous allez vous
présenter
bonjour je m'appelle quand un amour je
suis allée comme francis rêve hier à
l'etang-salé pour jour que mantel mari
monsieur l'école francis rivière à étang
salé a dû de l'anah nicolas l'homme
assurera la liste série dalo alors on
commence par le la première partie
calcul automatisé premiers calculs 650
-30 2 618 c'est une bonne réponse
deuxième calcul 73 x 107 1300 la réponse
est correct tu vas pas un poids
troisième calcul
elle est le double de 805 me sauve 10
610 c'est une bonne réponse je m'apprête
à la deuxième partie calcul réfléchit on
peut prendre des notes
premier problème à la station service
pour remplir le réservoir de sa voiture
qui contient 48 litres
l'ugta ajoute 29 litres quelle quantité
d'essence restent et ils dans le
réservoir à la station-service remplir
le réservoir disons filtre ta réponse
est correct un tube à un point deuxième
problème dans une camionnette
un agriculteur change 22 caisses de
fraises pesant chacune 4 kg et huit
caisses d'orange pesant chacune 12 kilos
qu'elle mars en kilos at il chargé dans
sa camionnette dans une camionnette
un apiculteur charge 22 caisses de
fraises pesant chacune 4 kg et huit
caisses d'orange pesant chacune 12 kg
quelle masse en kilos at il changé dans
ma camionnette 184 kg c'est une bonne
réponse tient pas alors comme il lui
reste un dernier problème on fait un
petit point
à ce moment d'épreuve 3 à 2 en faveur de
malaga et 3,2 donc quand tu peut
égaliser sur le troisième problème lui
et yanis joue à un jeu vidéo
l'udc à un scot 536 points
yanis doivent gagner encore 154 points
pour avoir le même score que l'udc
tel est le score de yanis 382 réponse
exacte
tu marques un point alors le score final
donc les deux candidats se retrouvent à
ex-aequo donc qu'on va passer à la
question subsidiaire je vais expliquer
juste le principe donc revenir à des
calculs automatisés donc là vous allez
poser les stylos s'il vous plaît vous
n'en avez plus besoin et c'est le même
principe que tout à l'heure chaque
calcul élu deux fois
vous avez le droit à prêt à 10 secondes
maximum de réflexion et à tout moment
vous pouvez aussi est le premier qui
aura une bonne réponse à une question
subsidiaire sera donc qualifié pour la
prochaine étape 1 alors donc la question
subsidiaire
9h25 plus 15 minutes
9h40
c'est une réponse exacte alors donc le
score final 4-3 mari et trois pour
compte
c'est bien ça bon donc c'est ma équipes
qualifiées pour la finale
alors donc nous continuons avec le
niveau cm maintenant pour la deuxième
manche alors que c'est ils sont bien
placés dans les 2 ce qui
aloïs ici et nous alors vous allez vous
présenter
bonjour je m'appelle aloïs cazenga je
viens de l'école application belle paire
de chaussures un serment à saint denis
deux abonnés de coucou alors on va
commencer par la première partie calcul
automatisé premiers calculs 135,50 +78
aghiles 23
135,50 plus 70,22
200 5,73
c'est une bonne réponse tu m'as qu'un
poids deuxième calcul quel est le tiers
de 921 quel est le tiers de 921 307
c'est une bonne réponse tu me réponds à
ton tour 3e calcul entre parenthèses 72
plus 28 x entre parenthèses 75 + 25
dix mille réponses exactes que ma
compagne de la deuxième partie calcul
réfléchit on peut prendre vos stylos
premier problème
jacques habite à 300 mètres du collège
chaque jour il effectue deux
allers-retours à pas régulier quelle
longueur en kilomètres
paco at-il chaque jour chat habite à 300
mètres du collège
chaque jour il effectue deux
allers-retours à pas régulier
quelle longueur en kilomètres paco at-il
chaque jour
le temps est écoulé non non il reste
encore le temps est écoulé tout là vous
ne pouvez plus répond des explications
puisqu'il fait deux allers retours de
300 m 2 x 300 ça fait six ans et donc ça
fait 1,2 km deuxième problème pour la
rentrée des classes le libre et avançant
paquet de feutre à 6 euros l'un et 50
boîtes de peinture à 8 euros l'une
quelle somme at il reçu pour ses
articles pour la rentrée des classes le
libre et avançant paquet de feutre à 6
euros l'un et 50 boîtes de peinture à 8
euros l'une quelle somme at il reçu pour
ses articles
réponse exacte du matin alors donc comme
ils voient ce déni problème on fait un
petit peu alors à ce moment de l'épreuve
aloïs à trois points et nous amène à 1
donc on passe au troisième dernier
sébastien prend des cours de guitare il
a déjà assisté à cinq séances et à payer
90 euros combien coûte une séance de
guitare sébastien prend des cours de
guitare il a déjà assisté à cinq séances
et à payer 90 euros
combien coûte une cellule de guitare
barreiro ce n'est pas une bonne réponse
la pie x billets écoutez la réponse
alors cinq séances à 90 euros 90 / 5 ce
qui fait 18 euros la séance
personne ne parle de poids bon là donc
le résultat
donc c'est aloïs qui est le vainqueur
3-1 donc aloïs battu revient pour la
finale de c1 à tout à l'heure
donc on va passer maintenant à noah et
nous y aura ici de voir ma gauche
et nous alors alors vous allez vous
présenter
bonjour je m'appelle noir piot je viens
de l'école francis rivière ce cm2 bel
étang salé bonjour je m'appelle noé
leveneur et je suis un cm2 dans l'école
catholique de son club alors on va
commencer par la première partie calcul
automatisé premiers calculs 32 minutes
15 secondes plus 26 minutes 45 secondes
59 minutes
réponse exacte du macumba deuxième
calcul 25 x 32 x 4 3200 réponse exacte
tu m'as qu'encore un pont troisième
calcul entre parenthèses 112 - 13 / 3
33 c'est une bonne réponse trois points
2e partie calcul réfléchi ou peut
prendre aussi l'eau premier problème
hier pierre a vendu 30 kg de tomates
aujourd'hui il en vend cinq ans soit 100
de plus combien y at il vendu 2 kg de
tomates aujourd'hui 45 kg c'est une
bonne réponse
tuba qu'un pont deuxième problème
lucas à 90 y
jean-paul en a 40
combien lucas doit-il donner du bia jean
paul c'est une bonne réponse
troisième et dernier problème
mathieu à 240 km à parcourir
après une déroute
il a fait un tiers du trajet
quelle distance qui reste utile à
parcourir 160 km
réponse exacte ans tu m'appeler dénis
points fabien la bravo il a fait un sans
faute donc résultats des donc
ces noix donc noah est qualifié pour la
finale de cm 2 et il rejoindra donc
antoine en finale
donc là maintenant on va c'est la finale
danse et émile et on va faire donc la
finale l'essai de la finale les cm la
finale des scènes de combat commençait
bien sûr pas par des cm2 s'est blessé
deux alors anneau en or ici à gauche
comme à gauche
bailly si on n'a pas de maintenant vous
allez vous êtes arrivé en finale et
maintenant ces deux celui qui gagne va
et des finalistes
il va pâtir pas comique
alors vous allez vous présenter je
m'appelle en haut je suis en ce2 je suis
à l'école des passants à son mari
bonjour je m'appelle france
alors on va commencer donc pas la
première partie calcul automatisé
premiers calculs 5 x 2405 multiplier
2438 ce n'est pas une bonne réponse
10800 toujours pas la réponse n'est pas
correct en deuxième calcul 5 x 2400 5 x
2000 ça fait dix mille sa foi 400 ça
fait 2000 dix mille plus 2000
ça fait douze mille la réponse était
12000 la deuxième calcul entre
parenthèses 35 + 19 x 1000
54 milles c'est une bonne réponse
troisième calcul
quel est le triple de 207 6 121 réponse
exacte qui manqueront pas alors calcul
réfléchi ou le prendre aussi le premier
problème dans une famille on utilise
chaque jour 55 litres d'eau pour la
cuisine et 245 litres pour la toilette
et le nettoyage calcul en litres la
quantité d'eau utilisée dans une semaine
chacun 1000 litres non ce n'est pas une
bonne réponse dans une famille on
utilise chaque jour à 55 litres d'eau
pour la cuisine demi cent litres la
réponse est correct que tu m'accompagnes
deuxième problème une association dans
la classe 2e et les six ont récolté 95
euros et les garçons ont récolté 38
euros de moins que les filles
combien d'argent la classe 2e et atel
récoltés en tout
133 euros
la réponse des fosses pour une
association dans la classe de zoé
les six ont récolté 95 euros et les
garçons ont récolté 169 euros
la réponse n'est toujours pas bonnes il
nous reste dernier problème
l'explication alors les filles ont
récolté 95 euros
les garçons en ont récolté 38 de moins
donc ce qu'ils ont récolté 95 - 38
ce qui fait 57 auquel on ajoute aux 95
95 57 152 alors maintenant donc comme il
reste le dernier problème on a fait un
petit point
alors à ce moment-là et à trois points
et on en a aucun problème
un scooter qui coûte 915 euros
aujourd'hui vos 80 euros de moins
qu'hier
quel était son pays 835 euros
ce n'est pas la bonne réponse un scooter
qui compte 915 euros aujourd'hui vos 80
euros de moins qu'hier
quel était son prix
1125 euros non ce n'est pas la bonne
réponse alors qu'elles étaient la bonne
réponse
195 euros la réponse est correct tu vas
plus un poids le dernier nom il va pas
prêt il manquerait quand je lui
demandais parce que il avait été miné
son temps pour voir s'il avait trouvé
après donc que le résultat amour 0 il
m'a dit il encore mallet donc et
finaliste et wi fi nalistes urbania
finale tu remplis
donc on va maintenant passer donc à la
finale des cm1 donc c'est la dernière
manche 1 celui ou celle qui gagnera
paris et bien vous allez vous présenter
à nouveau
joséphine je suis en scène un local
novation afin que marie bonjour jeu mais
je m'appelle alice casalonga je suis en
cm1 à l'école applications mail pierre
de saint denis
allez on commence cette finale
maintenant avec la première partie
premiers calculs 692 +97 692 +97 789
réponse exacte
tu marques un point deuxième calcul 36 x
25 36 x 25
le temps est écoulé dont quatre points
alors la réponse était donc 36 x 25 900
personnes ne marque deux points 3e
calcul
si on divise 168 par 4 puis que l'on
calcule le triple du résultat combiné
combien obtient dont si on divise 168 4
puis que l'on calcule le triple du
résultat
combien et piétons
le temps est écoulé
deuxième partie calcul réfléchir comme
explication alors 168 par quatre il
fallait voir des multiples donc 16 160
par quatre ça fait quarante huit ça fait
2 donc 42 fois 328 26 ans et on
passerait dans la deuxième partie calcul
réfléchi vous pouvez prendre vos cils
premier problème
alice possède 30 euros 50 et son frère
25 euros 50
ils achètent en commun un cadeau et il
leur reste 9 euros
combien ont-ils payé le cadeau
alice possède 30 euros 50 et son frère
25 euros 50 47 euros réponse exacte qui
marque un point deuxième problème
nick possède 38 photos de mammifères 32
photos de poissons 56 photos d'oiseaux
suis à chaque page de son classeur il
colle six photos
combien de pages ainsi compléter y at il
dans son classeur
possède 38 photos de mammifères 32
photos de poissons 56 photos d'animaux
c'est une bonne réponse alors fait un
petit point alors marion moment même de
trois points et aloïs zéro point alors
on pense à troisième problème
un marchand de fruits de légumes reçoit
300 kg de pommes de terre
le premier jour ils font 16 sacs de 10
kg et 10 à 2 5 kilos qu'elle marche de
pommes de terre lui restera-t-il à la
fin de la journée
un marchand de fruits réponse exacte
tu marques un point bas dans le résultat
final
alors c'est marion qui gagnent la partie
avec quatre points donc marion bien tuer
la grande finalistes de 2 cm pour c'est
à dire
donc il nous reste maintenant la
dernière finale des cm2 alors les deux
cm2 vous venez antoine à côté de moi ça
y est c'est bonjour je m'appelle en
traîneau à chiens je suis au cm2 à
l'école quand la lorraine de la
possession bonjour je m'appelle noir if
you had écoles francis riviera et en
salle est alors on commence cette finale
pour mia bâtie alors premiers calculs
37,85 plus 11,40 8,95 réponse exacte
tu m'as craint pas deuxième calcul
4h05 - 2h50 immerseel 1h45
ce n'est pas une bonne réponse 14h05 -
2h50
1h55
ce n'est pas une bonne réponse mais
c'était cadeau la réponse est 1h15
troisième calcul quel est le corps du
tiers de cent vingt dix réponses exactes
a tu m'as qu'un point à la deuxième
partie calcul réfléchir vous pouvez
aussi le premier problème la maquette
des bus à 14,6 cm de long sachant qu'un
centimètre de la maquette représente en
réalité 5 cm combien mesure la longueur
de l'oea bus en mètre 73 m
c'est une bonne réponse deuxième
problème dans une salle de spectacles de
164 places un corps de ces places sont à
demi tarif
combien y at-il de place à demi tarif 40
e c'est une bonne réponse
enfin petit point plus chéres un dernier
problème
alors en ce moment c'est noah qui mènera
coin alors dénis problème je suis
compris entre 3 198 et 412 je suis
multiple de 5
je ne suis pas un nombre pair qui
suis-je 395
la réponse n'est pas correct je suis
compris en 398 t400 12 405 réponse
exacte n'est vraiment qu'un pas de plus
alors le résultat final le résultat
fauna final c'est noah qui mène à 4
points donc finalistes donc d'avoir une
loi et donc finalistes
cette année en cm2 bravo voilà donc on a
terminé donc les trois niveaux ce2 cm1
cm2 et bien vous dis donc
à l'année prochaine messi
et